under stress of course a retired Harvard
Law School professor the most famous of
them all and the author of the case
against impeaching Trump he joins us now
to help sort this out professor thanks a
lot for coming on so the Manfred story I
think seems pretty cut and dry he was
convicted of tax evasion sounds like he
did it I don't think many people are
surprised Cohen however part of this
guilty pleas surrounds money that he
moved apparently from Trump's accounts
to a woman who alleged sexual contact
with Trump that's a very common scenario
among famous people as you know we've
seen a lot of that in the last year
people paying off women who say they had
sexual contact with the affluent person
is that illegal how is that a crime well
itself it's not a crime and if the
president had paid it directly it
wouldn't be a crime the allegation here
is that it was Cohen who paid it and
made a campaign contribution which he
didn't report at the direction of the
president and of course some stations
are already playing the funeral music
for President Trump but this is much
more complicated and much more nuanced
first of all the crime itself is very
very vague they try to put edwards the
former presidential candidate on trial
and of course they got an acquittal but
second it really required depends
completely on the credibility of cohen
and remember as judge Ellis said when
they squeeze people like Madoff or or
Cohen they squeeze them not only to sing
but sometimes to compose and it's very
easy to embellish a story let's assume
hypothetically it's true that he did pay
the money and it was designed to help
the impact of the election that wouldn't
involve the president all he has to do
that is say and the president directed
me to do it that's the kind of
embellishment that people put on a story
when they want to avoid dying in prison
when the prosecutor says to them you
have two choices
you'll die in prison or you can give me
a story that I can use to go and get the
president I'm not suggesting that happen
here but the risk of that happening is
what judge Ellis talked about in in the
metaphor case and we may see that at
work here so we're a long way from
you know tolling the bells for this
administration it's a it's a negative
day it's a not a for not not a fatal one
yeah but I'm still a bit confused so
something comes to you and says if
somebody says to you and you're running
for office and the person says give me
money or I will humiliate you in public
and you do give that person money or
Instructor lawyer to give that person
money that's a campaign donation not if
you make it yourself but if somebody
else pays the money in order to
influence the outcome of the election
it is technically perhaps a violation of
the election laws that's what they try
to get Edwards on it didn't work they
got an acquittal and hung jury and they
never tried him again
but you know again violation of election
laws are regarded as kind of jaywalking
in the realm of things about elections
and there are so many of them every
administration violates the election
laws every candidate violates the
election laws when they run for
president usually they pay a fine
something like that happens here they're
trying to elevate this into an
impeachable offense or a felony against
the president right look they may name
the president as an unindicted
co-conspirator they did that with Nixon
even back then where I complained about
that because naming somebody as an
unindicted co-conspirator is very unfair
because he has no opportunity to defend
himself or herself and yet that may
happen so this is the beginning of a
story that will unravel over time but
it's not nearly as deadly lethal as some
have portrayed it as being it's
certainly confusing as a matter of law
but it professor thank you for for
explaining that